Film Courage: What are five steps to writing
a bad book? Kim O'Hara, Author/Book Coach,
Speaker/Podcaster: Only talking about
yourself without a a purpose or a mission
of something that you want to
have the reader experience like
joy or a journey or an emotional release.
I'm talking more in memoir and self-help.
Using language like "it" and "this" and
"maybe" and "perhaps" in kind of vague terms
instead of rewriting the sentences. Every
sentence should be a thing of beauty.
It's a book, take your time to make
every line matter. Don't just think well
those sentences were good, these can be kind of a
slough off. Rewrite, make every sentence beautiful
Don't aim low, don't decide I'm just going
to write an ebook and give it away for free
on your website. I don't think...that's not
really a book. Honor books, they're boundable,
they're thicker, it's something you want
to hand to someone and be proud of not some
door stop or something i'm going to use
to balance my computer. That's four and
five would be write one draft and then
publish it. Film Courage: Why would someone
do that? Kim: People do it all the time, they're
like that was brilliant, nailed it in one shot
and they just discount the whole process. That
was just the beginning you read it you can tell
you can tell when someone's published a fir you
don't see that in profession professional but you
see that in you know when i was in like networking
groups or like you know first started my business
people would write books in 90 days or whatever
and you're like i don't want to read it please
don't give me your book this is what i what
i'd be thinking because it would just be fluffy
it would spin it where they were
it
to really dig in and write a memoir in
a short period of time i don't think
it's got enough heft it hasn't been expanded
enough um maybe to write a book about dating
like 101 tips to date you might be able to do
that in a first draft um or 10 tips to good
sales calls you might be able to do that in one
draft but i don't tend to work with those books
when you read an author's work and they
write about themselves into positive alight
how do you break that down because we've all read
books where oh yeah it was written by this ceo
or this person and they're just telling
their grand vision and it paints them
as this saint whereas when you read about a
third party writing about that same individual
it's much juicier it's a full person warts and all
so how do you when you see somebody's being too
pollyanna about themselves how do you say are we
really getting honest here i don't ever get that
i don't ever get that i think that there's a
lot of self-deprecation in the clients that come
to me i think that they've been through enough
of the rough road that self-deprecation is not
it's not so far from them and um if
anything we're trying to get them to
be more positive about themselves and and
see where their beautiful gifts are and see
how what they've written about and what they've
been through inform so much about who they are
um i don't i can't think of one experience where
someone just wants to write about their positive
experiences i mean i have had those conversations
where people have called me and they're like
well i'm going to write a book about and i and
i feel like kind of a cynic going but where's
the darkness right especially when they say
well there really isn't anything dark about
my story and i think oh i don't know if that's
possible who wants to read it where did you live
yeah would you say a lot of new writers write
books that are mediocre or have no essence
no not at all i mean i think it's i think
everybody's a new writer on any project you start
i'm a new writer even though i've been writing
since i was 12 years old um anytime you take on
a new narrative or a new group of characters or
maybe a new style of writing or you're going into
new territory you're new you know you might have
more of a bag of tools with you you might know
better paragraph structure you might do
better bridges in and out of your chapters
you might know not to bring in too many
characters in the whole kitchen sink
you might have your themes broken down your
why broken down and your bigger message and
you know who you're writing for and you know
what you're an expert in but you're still new
it's still a fresh slate you're still gonna
have all the same butterflies in your stomach
you're still gonna have all the same you know
disembarking on this like amazing journey and
i always say books are a journey not a
destination you're really not ever really
getting anywhere even like you're you're in a
journey like if you get there the journey's over
books should continue forever explain to me what
a bridge is between chapel a bridge is leading
out of one chapter into the next chapter so it it
either summarizes and concludes the the first the
chapter that's just ending and leads you into the
next chapter with a flow so you don't feel just
that one chapter ends and then the next chapter
starts there's some kind of with fiction it's a
little bit different especially if you're jumping
around locations but there is some kind of there's
a there's a skill involved in leading the reader
in through like a tapestry of the chapters and
that's what the bridges do and that's really what
we do in the third draft as we work on the bridges
how can you tell a story is boring or it's
wandering what tips do you have to like
you said with the one gentleman who had an
interesting career but it needed it needed
these 15 tips i like people to write their story
first first draft before i start killing their
babies is what i the way i call it and that's um
i get pretty brutal like i'll start to go through
and just be like why do we care and who's this for
and what does this do and why do we need this and
if i get some pushback i'll listen because there
could be something that isn't really be being said
and we'll have sometimes like a debate about
it like well what do you mean that the the the
that you say that this is about that character's
evolution i don't see any evolution here at all i
see you're just washing dishes in the kitchen
with their grandmother where's the evolution
well the grandmother threw the thing and well
you didn't write that the grandmother threw the
thing you just wrote oh then they go and write it
and it's now a scene that almost is like required
so you don't try to you don't try to throw up you
might have entire storylines that just go right
because sometimes it seems all seems relevant
on the first draft and then in the second draft
we don't need everybody to know every single
part of your life we just need the parts that
serve the themes that are running through
and if that chunk does not serve the theme
they're not going to know the difference whether
you kept it out or not because they don't know you
they only know what you're going to tell them you
want them to know so if we're like oh grandpa john
he would make these great birdhouses and he's
just no do we is grandpa john necessary right
to the story oh he was a really cool guy he
was i would we would watch these no no is he
necessary right no grandpa john's gone sorry yeah
and how do people feel about that when it's like
that was grandpa john he's got to be in the store
he was a big part of the family but there wasn't
enough and i'm like you can put grandpa john in
the book for grandpa john but that's not going to
help your book we need to focus on the book what
does the book need what is you know maybe you can
write a little letter to grandpa john or something
put them in the put them in the acknowledgments
okay right with a picture no well that's right
we're not doing pictures no pictures no graphics
you